l'autosuffisance complète en fruits et
légumes en fait rêver plusieurs mais
comment arriver à faire pousser des
végétaux à l'année longue
dans un climat nordique comme le nôtre
un couple du centre du québec a relevé
le défi grâce à une serre inusité
[Musique]
salif a dit qu'on était un peu fou c'est
juste naturel la force la géothermie
pilaire le soleil qui tâchent officie au
lieu d'aller à l'épicerie une fois par
semaine on peut y aller une fois en
trois semaines
[Musique]
nous sommes à fortierville une petite
communauté de 700 âmes située dans le
centre du québec sur la rive sud du
saint laurent
c'est ici en bordure de ce petit village
paisible que l'on trouve ce bâtiment un
peu étrange
donc on y est oui ça pourrait ressembler
le terrain de camping mais c'est
vraiment la faire et on entre ici on
entouré par le toit
au votre piale si je pars succès ça
c'était réellement fait peur vraiment
chaud beaucoup d'humidité
oui beaucoup d'humilité beaucoup de
chaleur grâce à cette chaleur et cette
humidité
la végétation est abondante peu importe
la saison
pamela et félix cueille fruits et
légumes huit pieds sous terre
ces quelques récoltes au moins par année
oui on a fait le printemps tôt au
printemps on en fait aussi l'été on peut
en faire même jusqu'à 200 porcs nous on
s'est livré manteau puis aussi à
l'automne puis durant y va on prend les
légumes qui poussent bien soute et les
carottes les salades
pamela est naturopathe de profession ça
faisait des années qu'elle et son
conjoint rêvait de ce projet de serres
souterraine chez eux dans le coup moi je
veux être autosuffisante quand même
beaucoup qui apprendre aux enfants
trouvés stendhal valeur ils ont passé
près de deux ans a amassé de
l'information dans le but de dénicher la
serre la mieux adaptée à leurs besoins
et surtout la plus résistante à nous
redit vers leur choix là c'est roy
lippini en 2017 il se lance dans
l'aventuré
sur internet j'avais vu les phares ou à
lippini beaucoup en france ça qu'on
voulait creuser huit pieds vu qu'en
afrique nous permettait le sol à 8,6
shape oliver placer ou à lippini est une
structure à moitié enfoui dont la partie
hors terre et fait de toile transparente
pour laisser passer les rayons solaires
tout est conçu pour optimiser l'effet
géothermique
on profite de la chaleur relativement
stable du sol à une certaine profondeur
en plus d'optimiser le plus possible de
l'entrée de lumière comme thouet la
fenêtre dans les airs ce format pour
favoriser un échange à l'intérieur comme
ça ça permet aux abeilles et au bourdon
devenez pas l'elysée tous mes fruits à
l'intérieur pour être certain d'avoir un
rendement maximal
la serre où ali penny a été développée
pour répondre aux besoins des
populations rurales des hauts plateaux
boliviens
elle fait maintenant des adeptes en
france où l'on en trouve de plus en plus
félix et pamela ont décidé d'ajouter à
la structure habituelle de leroy lippini
un aménagement ankara d'un fait de 350
nos usagers l'hypno justement t il vont
le soir dégager la chaleur fac le sol il
va être chaud c'est vraiment juste ce
qui fait qu'on est capable de récolter
vac je dirais franchement ivan met la
main dessus
puis sans une certaine chaleur on a
vraiment fait sur mesure pour le climat
du québec
les pneus emmagasinent la chaleur
lorsqu'elle est disponible et la
restitue par temps froid et trouver des
plus âgés ici ce n'était pas un problème
du russell est trouvée 350 période avant
au garage familial se détériore que j'ai
démonté il ya vraiment tout contact avec
la terre à l'intérieur on a mis deux
membres à l'eau si le couple a tout de
même dû répondre à certaines exigences
du ministère de l'environnement avant
d'enfouir tous ses pneus dans leurs
serres
nous sommes à la mi juillet et déjà cet
écosystème artisanale qui est bien ses
promesses
la récolte est abondante on va tellement
leur école qu'on arrivera pas a tranché
mme annie simon chang soeur grand
mangeur les jeunes montrent qu'on veut
en faire un commerce ce moment donné
mais t on et des shows de commerce bac
c'est assez pour nous on veut pas se
lancer là dedans c'est vraiment notre
famille mais quand on a des surplus on
les donne à des gentils you régine
projet qui fait un petit resto fait que
quand ça va avoir avoir des aliments
frais
origine est la chef propriétaire de
l'auberge de fortier ville elle vient
aujourd'hui chercher quelques surplus de
légumes de la dernière récolte elle se
plaît à raconter long de choc qu'a
provoquée le projet du jeune couple à
ses débuts tout le monde en parlait dans
le village est très populaire
c'est ce que les gens trouvent un sens
un peu farfelu qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il
faut c'est quoi ce soir lors des insa
kiki qui marchent à 12 mois par année
casse castries
à chaque fois que quelque chose de
nouveau qui se fait surtout dans un
petit milieu
déjà ils sont inquiets et se demandent
ce qui va se passer
la mairesse de fortierville s'en
souvient très bien
elle avait assisté à quelques rencontres
d'information sur le projet de serres
souterraine de félix et pamela la
municipalité avait finalement décidé
d'accommoder le couple en modifiant
certains règlements de zonage
au début j'avais vraiment beaucoup
d'inquiétude de mère pamela effet l'ex
ont su rassurer la population explique
et comme il faut leur projet données
donnelly lettre du ministère qui avait
les autorisations avec le processus de
coma y aller le faire et puis ensuite
les gens sales usa sécurisé
quand on voit le résultat maintenant
s'est rendu tout le monde va enfin être
humain
[Musique]
c'est le cas de simon pierre lavigne qui
habite un peu plus loin dans le village
simon-pierre nous montre l'emplacement
de sa future sert souterraine
directement à partir elle à partir des
arbres un projet qu'il en tête depuis
qu'il a aidé félix et pamela à
construire leur installation
voyez trouvé ça très bonne idée et
surtout pour voir les fruits en hiver sa
parade est si ce serait pour moi
l'améliorer peut-être un petit peu
question d'avoir plus de chaleur
on voit l'engouement de la population
partout au québec pour ce genre de
projet de
ces cinq villages où beaucoup de
villages près à vos ressources s'apprête
vraiment merveilleux puis ça serait
comme un peu un rêve le
le rêve de pamela pourrait bien se
réaliser en deux ans trois maires
provenant d'autres municipalités au
québec sont venus visiter sa serre
souterraines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsque j'ai réussi j'ai eu alors et qu'
un petit copain versées sont ici leur
prix paiement je pense que c'était 100 m
de venir voir
en fait ce modèle ce modèle de serre
vous allez fini comme çà et facilement
un portable chez nous le maire
d'albertville dans le bas saint laurent
a fait cinq heures de route aujourd'hui
pour venir voir sur place la serbe de
pamela et félix est ce que tu considère
qu'une superficie de comme celle ici
comme chez toi c'est suffisant pour la
communauté mais ça n'est pas pour rien
si villa gillet pour le chrétien plus
grave la joue même à l'échelle d'une
collectivité
on est capable de construire ce genre de
serre puis on est capable implanté sur à
peu près n'importe quel terrain en
notant que la nappe phréatique soit pas
trop
il est bien déterminé à importer le
modèle loi lippini dans sa communauté
je pense qu'on va être en mesure d'ici
d'ici la prochaine année de pouvoir
implanter un projet de faire de ce type
l'eau ou un autre titre mais honnêtement
j'ai un petit penchant pour ce faire
mais pamela et félix la mettent ils ont
sous-estimé l'ampleur du défi en se
lançant dans un projet pareil ce serait
ce que pour tout le monde sur le côté
les équipements aussi tout est aussi un
minimum de tchita parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de taro aso
ça a été une très belle chanson le faire
c'est merveilleux on dit en plus en
famille
juste pour ça c'est vraiment ça vaut de
l'or
[Musique]
k way personnes
il dit